hi my name is Sarah Goodwin and today we
are talking to Susan McConnell who is
the susan b ford professor at Stanford
University than studies developmental
neurobiology and she is also an avid
nature and wildlife photographer so
thank you for joining us today it's my
pleasure with it Sarah thank you and I
thought I'd start off by just asking you
a little bit about your scientific
background and how you got interested in
science and what led you to pursue a
career in basic research so I'm a
developmental neurobiologist at Stanford
I've had a lab there for 22 years I was
a graduate student at Harvard and a
postdoc at Stanford but i think my
journey into developmental neurobiology
is really intrinsically connected with
my interest in wildlife photography so
when i was a little kid I used to go out
and watch animals as much as I could and
that included sitting for hours at a
woodpile where there were big families
of wood rats and I would watch them
might be fascinated by the social lives
of these rodents so when I was maybe 10
or 11 years old I thought oh you know I
loved horses I love to ride I thought
I'd be a horse trainer but then I saw a
National Geographic special on TV that
featured Jane Goodall and the
chimpanzees of gombe in Tanzania and
there was this extraordinary view of you
know romantic view of this beautiful
young woman who is spending her life in
nature studying our closest relatives
getting close to these animals getting
getting them to trust her and seeing
amazing things about their behavior that
now we know inform us about our own
origins and our similarities and
differences to our sort of closest
genetic cousins so I was so inspired by
seeing Jane Goodall that I wanted to be
a scientist that led me into initial
forays and looking at animal behavior
mostly in the laboratory and that then
led to an interest in the difference in
behaviors that are innate versus learned
so how is it that some animals are just
born with the ability to exhibit very
complex behaviors and other behaviors
have to be learned steadily and
progressively being modeled so I thought
about behavior and innate versus learned
what is that really talking about it's
talking about the brain it's talking
about neural circuits and how they get
wired in what kinds of circuitry are
hard-wired to enable the performance of
these complex behaviors and how do
circuits get modified and then that
ultimately led me into my interest now
as a developmental neurobiologist in how
those circuits form during development
so it's a long but actually pretty
linear progressive progression from
being fascinated by animal behavior to
studying brain development in the lab so
you've always had an interest in animal
behavior what led you into the
photography aspect of observing animal
behavior there is a way of being present
when you're taking pictures that is
extraordinarily thoughtful and engaged
because as a photographer you're not
just responding to what you see you're
really searching for how to communicate
with an audience an idea an emotion a
sense of what you're seeing photography
is a is a form of visual communication
and searching for that message is
interesting so for example I was in the
makati Cody pan of Botswana and had gone
there specifically to photograph
meerkats these wonderful desert
creatures that are extraordinarily
social and I went there because there
was a very well known group of meerkats
that were highly habituated to people
and as a photographer photographing
animals are habituated which is
different than trained but habituated
animals really lets you get close and up
close and personal with them when I got
to this site what I first found was that
new babies had just emerged from the den
so my first pictures were really
focusing on the wonder of these new
babies and as the babies actually
started to interact with their parents
I started to play around with light
backlighting front lighting the grouping
of the animals the behavior and so on
and so what you don't want to take the
same picture over and over you want to
change your point of view and try to
find a unique perspective what happened
then was really cool a huge marabou
stork which is a predator of small
animals like meerkats landed and this
whole group of meerkats that had been
dispersed and feeding gathered together
for safety and then I started to play
with a set of images that explored the
geometry of that gathering as they were
all focused on a particular point in
space but i was still searching for what
you can think of as an image that would
really convey something about not only
these animals in their behavior but but
how it is that they survive in this
environment and it was at that point i
thought oh my god i've got the wrong
lens on my camera I've been shooting
them close close close and exploring
their relationships in their geometry
but they are exposed they're exposed
next to a predator so I changed to a
wide angle lens got in front of the
animals the Sun was setting the light
was beautiful I had to put a flash on
just to light them a little bit from the
front to fill up their faces and that
then resulted in the image from that
couple of hours spent with meerkats that
I think of as an image that communicates
not only about these animals but their
relationships and their vulnerability in
the place where they live do you think
your approach to photography can almost
be described as scientific part of the
art of photography is responding to
light and if you're a wildlife
photographer to behavior and
conceptualizing how it is to represent
that moment through the camera but
photography is also a highly technical
art because the camera is a machine and
so in order to understand how to
translate what's happening out there
into the vision I have of how to
communicate that that I have in my mind
I need to understand enough basic optics
and physics
to put the right settings on the camera
to cut the right depth of field to know
whether I want a sharp image or a
blurred image what's the what's going to
communicate the feeling that I want to
transmit through this image and also
there are properties of the sensor and
how it detects light that determine how
one will if one will even try to take a
particular picture under particular
light lighting or circumstances so
photography is one of those fields where
the intersection between art and science
are very very close so can you tell us a
little bit about one of your most
memorable experiences in the field I
think for me one of the most satisfying
experiences and exciting experiences
that I've had was nearly three weeks
spend at a single water hole one water
hole in Namibia with katelyn O'Connell
Rodwell who's a researcher has been
studying elephants for 25 years I was
given the assignment to shoot pictures
of the story that caitlyn was writing
about the social relationships between
bull elephants and largely our sense of
male elephants that they're mostly
solitary and they might hang out with
buddies at waterholes for a little while
but Caitlyn had discovered that these
male elephants form very long-term
hierarchical relationships that involve
coalition's and you know like a boss and
underlings who sort of carry out the
boss's orders and it's very interesting
and fascinating by spending that period
of time with Kaitlyn and her colleagues
I learned an enormous amount about
elephant behavior I was able to see
things in the way that they interact
with one another the way that the
approach one another sometimes with
anxiety and sometimes with aggression
they can square off and have really
interesting fights with one another
there's also a very specific behavior
that Kaitlyn and her colleagues had
observed again and again where a
subservient elephant puts his trunk to
the mouth of a more dominant ball it's
an appeasement gesture it's the same
thing in the baby elephant would do to
his mother
and and also got to observe not only the
relationships between the Bulls but the
arrivals of these large breeding herds
of elephants as they come to the water
hole there's chaos there's dust flying
and especially if I was in an
underground bunker very very close to
some of these elephants they would get
sent of me and then get these
extraordinarily aggressive displays
aimed at me thank goodness I was safe so
so that was a privilege to be able to
get so close to elephants to see so much
of their behavior that you wouldn't i
wouldn't have observed on my own without
being around researchers it gave me the
ability to predict behavior accurately
to I knew when I could just sit back and
relax and watch the scene and when I
needed to grab both cameras and be ready
because all chaos was going to break
loose could he tell us a little bit more
about some of the places you've been to
there are just so many extraordinary
places on the planet including in our
own backyard that have amazing animals
behavior experiences that one can have
with with nature i'm addicted to Africa
I'm going on my 15th trip there next
month which sounds like a lot but it's
nothing compared to the people actually
live there I had a really remarkable
opportunity to spend some time with
mountain gorillas first in Uganda
several years ago and then more recently
in Rwanda as extraordinary as it is to
watch animals you know be hate living
playing fighting nursing their babies
eating all of those things are amazing
but for me the most emotional moment
that I had in Rwanda was at a moment
when group of guerrillas were very close
to a stone fence that separated the
volcanoes national park a very small
reserve where some of the last remaining
mountain gorillas are protected from
neighbouring areas villages but that are
cultivated farmland and one by one these
gorillas went and sat on this stone
fence looking out
and in the distance were some people
from the local village looking back at
the gorillas to me that sort of
recognition by these animals that this
was a boundary and the way that they
looked out at land that used to be
theirs and yet is preserving them now
the local people and we as tourists
preserving them now was an
extraordinarily moving experience and I
think a picture like this one really
captures that complex relationship that
we have with the natural world right now
have your experiences as a nature
photographer affected your life as a
scientist my experience says is a
photographer have had a lot of effects
on my life as a scientist I think most
importantly it's made me feel happy and
whole that there is something I feel
passionate about when things in the lab
aren't going well that I can explore
even in my own backyard the elephant
seals at Annja nuevo or the the
hummingbirds that frequent are our
literal backyards or the burrowing owls
that live around here are these teeny
little owls that are just adorable so
it's it's very easy actually to go quite
close to home and to have one of these
experiences that makes you feel
rejuvenated and refreshed so as you
became more passionate about nature and
wildlife photography how did you balance
that with your career as a scientist
yeah there are a lot of different
passions that I think we scientists have
photography being my example right now
that can take a lot of time and I think
for me it was very important to realize
that there are seasons in their career
there are times of one's career for
example the time at which you're first
starting your lab where you need to
immerse yourself 24-7 in building your
group in getting your research off the
ground and so these are not times when
you'd want to take off for a month and
photograph you know gorillas in Rwanda
because you're needed
at home and your career depends on that
sort of real deep investment of self in
in in your science and yet as a lab
matures and as students become more
self-reliant and the lab reaches point
where it can function for chunks of time
without for example me being there so
it's always a juggling act but I think
that one's priorities shift not only
over a career but even from month to
month and from year to year a time at
which when students you know need you
because they've got to get their papers
out is not a time to abandon ship and
then there are other times during the
year that are more flexible and it's
easier to pay some attention at least to
these other parts of life
you